happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you
today would have been kobe bryant's 42nd
birthday
and his wife vanessa is celebrating her
late husband with a heartbreaking
tribute
in the emotional letter to kobe the
mother of four wrote on instagram that
she wishes she could wake up from this
horrible nightmare
she admits she wanted to go first so
that i selfishly didn't have to feel
this heartache
you were supposed to miss me gigi was
supposed to be here with her sisters
it should have been me i have a house
full of women
wife three daughters another daughter on
the way
so you say every day day is truly that
in my house and that's just how it is
vanessa says she misses kobe's hugs
kisses
and his smile i think about everything
you would do in situations to help me
deal with everything thrown my way
i think about your tenderness and
patience all the time
the 38 year old went on to also remember
her 13 year old daughter gianna
who died with her dad in a helicopter
crash in january
gigi is a basketball player she is the
she's in it
does she have that inner focus like her
daddy yeah she's uh she's a stone cold
killer out there
yeah yeah at both ends of the floor i
mean she plays defense as well as
offense man she competes
vanessa shared how life feels so empty
without kobe
and gigi i've been completely broken
inside
as much as i want to cry i put a smile
on my face to make
our daughter's days shine a little
brighter
vanessa says her three girls natalia
bianca
and capri continue to help her every day
and are reminders of her beloved husband
i'm not the strong one they are they're
strong and resilient
i'm sure you're proud of them they put a
smile on my face
every day vanessa concluded her letter
by thanking her late husband writing
thank you for loving me enough to last
several lifetimes
in every lifetime i would choose you
thank you for showing me what real love
is
thank you for everything i know my gigi
is celebrating you like she always has
on our special days while it won't be
the same without kobe and gigi
the lakers legend is still being
celebrated on a special day by many
we have you know three beautiful healthy
you know uh
young ladies and with another one on the
way so
just just very very fortunate man kobe's
oldest daughter natalia reflected on
their good times writing
happy birthday to the best movie buddy i
could have ever
asked for i will always remember our
late night drives to the movie theater
with the windows rolled down
and listening to our favorite songs all
right here we go
like i said today is colin bride's 30th
birthday and we're going to say happy
birthday
on three lebron james shared this
throwback video from
kobe's 30th birthday where he got the
entire room to sing to the basketball
player
[Applause]
former teammate pal gasol who recently
spent time with vanessa and her
daughters
posted a touching tribute to kobe he
wrote
with tears in my eyes today i just wish
so badly that you were here
celebrating your birthday with your
girls and family i miss you and gigi
so much brother i will always be
thankful for how much you have impacted
my life in so many different ways
it means everything it means everything
lastly
both nike and the mamba and mamacita
sports foundation posted tributes to the
basketball player ahead of kobe bryant
day
which is on monday august 24th
kobe taught us to be better pushing and
pushing wake up every single day to get
better today than you were yesterday
better dreamer better waker
better stretcher better walker better
blocker
better sprinter better loser better
winner just be
better do the simple stuff right the day
will represent the two jersey numbers
8 and 24 which kobe wore during his
legendary nba career
mama
forever